okay
and and yeah and you got it
back on perfect yes perfect
everything is as it should be um yeah
fits perfectly yes absolutely
oh i love this oh he's got the thing
he's gonna
you son of a [ __ ]
ah he's back he is back welcome back to
new rockstars this is our reaction to
the mandalorian season 2
episode 6 chapter 14 the tragedy but
can we really call it a tragedy if boba
fett is reunited with his armor
and finally lives up to his badass
reputation in live action
yeah yeah the razor crest is destroyed
grogu is kidnapped we
are very scared but hey straight to
tithe on
we get slave one some details about
django dark troopers the dark saber
bill burr there is no filler thanks
robert rodriguez
this is wikileaks our mandalorian
aftershow i'm eric boss here with tommy
beck told hey buddy
hey good to be here what uh what an
episode
no filler is almost selling it short
every element of that episode was
uh was all meat all sweet sweet
baby yogurt meat a lot of meat on that
bone a lot of meat on that bone i i
took a improv workshop one time where
the exercise was like try to uh
figure out whether a detail has some uh
something worth exploring whether you
follow that
through line in the in the scene and the
the coach kept saying like
how much meat on that bone all right
about past months plus how much meat on
that bone
and everyone on the team is like what
the hell are you talking about
what does that mean on that bone yeah i
love that
it's like those are what were they the
crate dragon filet mignons that they
left
oh yeah there was a lot of great dragon
meat today a lot of me man that
crate dragon filet is what this episode
was
absolutely so much stuff uh and as you
can tell i'm back in the blue dungeon
welcome back so good to see you back i'm
back in my mom's room so
we're both more productive in our home
only for a few more weeks though very
excited to debut
my la studio in uh january so
you guys gotta stick around to see what
tommy's come up with barring me not
being terminated for any christmas
content that i put out
oh also before we begin a reminder that
you can get your limited edition this is
the way shirt exclusive from new
rockstars official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com we might
still have a few more red and white
varieties but after the last of them are
gone
back in the vault they go but if you
miss it don't worry there are also
a bunch of new designs we got some
easter egg
shirts they're filled with like hidden
references to find
we got a boom you're looking for this
shirt and we just released an amazing
new
grogu mug shot shirt uh it's amazing
how fast we got this out there and i
love this shirt definitely get your
hands on that and oh and
as always when you buy this this is a
white shirt for just a few bucks more
you can also write in
a custom shout out or a hot take a
theory or question
something that's gonna appear beneath us
in these wikileaks episode
um and you can actually see a couple uh
let's see christina guccione says happy
birthday mitch
i love you so much i'll never get tired
of watching this channel with you
oh she's a keeper mitch
she might be your mom oh yeah oh yeah
never mind mitch either way she's still
a keeper still she's your mom keeper as
well she's a wonderful mother
uh also annetti hernandez says colby if
you see this i'll send you fifty dollars
whoa so hopefully you see this colby
if you see this you owe eric and i five
dollars each as a commissioner
so yeah yeah yeah just a finders fee
uh so we appreciate that uh all right
tommy
there's a lot that happened this episode
why don't you break it down for us
oh boy yes a lot that happened in this
episode but as we said all
fillers so the mandalorian arrives with
grogu
on python immediately immediately we're
often banging he finds the ancient
temple on top of a mountain
not really hidden i wouldn't say
particularly hidden it's the highest
point on the planet ostensibly yeah and
a planet that looks a lot like
southern california yeah like all right
it's definitely southwest
i was surprised there wasn't a
mysterious monolith popping up but uh
so so mandalore does uh exactly what
we'd expect him to do he puts grogu
right on the rock in the center so that
grogu can
choose his path but of course because
groga is a 50 year old toddler
he misbehaves doesn't really do what
he's supposed to do
which is frustrating then finally he
starts meditating and a protective force
field appears
around him just in time for boba fett to
arrive with mercenary fenix shand
complete with a robo abdomen uh like a
steampunk stomach
i would say which that's like when when
tommy and i start working out together
that's the kind of abs i want just like
a machine
that does it for me absolutely i want a
steampunk stomach by
march at the latest uh so you know we
had theorized a lot about what was gonna
happen so
uh we actually see that boba fett is
pursuing them to get his armor back his
mandalorian armor back mando is
immediately like
no uh you're not a mandalorian and then
they they make a deal
that boba fett and fenix hand will help
him protect grogu
as long as he returns the armor just as
two shuttles arrive
uh chock full of storm troopers who
cannot aim so
traditional storm troopers as we know
based on the fact that they can shoot uh
anyone wearing best car
that's it yeah i do love that one called
the other an idiot
that was wonderful uh the two shuttles
arrive
and the stormtroopers just kind of they
filter out they get gunned down
we get boba fett returning he goes he
goes to steal his armor back
and boy can i relate to this moment like
anyone who's ever tried to put something
on that's like
fit them 20 years ago uh felt for a boba
fett when he walked in and was like i
now wear a black turtleneck under my
armor to cover up where the armor
doesn't completely connect it's like
when i try on my old like football
jerseys from high school or like when i
wear my like
my jackets that i had when i was in high
school
it's it's very nostalgic but ultimately
not very functional for comfort no
yeah for when i uh did the infinity fan
show that you were part of i got this
like
form-fitting spider-man unitard and i it
was right after i went through a period
of uh
starting to lose a lot of weight so it
just fit me okay right and then like
just six months later
we did a breakdown of uh of end game on
the channel
and then i had to put back on that
spider-man costume for a bit at the end
and it did not fit the same i
i tell you that's the story of my life
my weight has fluctuated so much over my
adult life that like
things that fit me even like a year ago
like you said will be like you know a
baby doll t-shirt on me the next day so
anyway back to uh back to a fun fantasy
world where no one cares about your
weight or counting calories
uh yeah or running from boulders that
are rolling directly towards you
little indiana jones vibe so we get uh
so so the agreement's intact fetch and
the mandalorian they join forces they
battle off the advancing stormtroopers
they kill most of them uh or at least
bludgeon them and cause permanent brain
damage with that uh
send person staff that uh get a gaffy
stick
yeah exactly helmets there you go that's
the correct
thank you for identifying the correct
name of the uh armor so that i
our weapon so that i don't have to
probably said it wrong
it's not it's a it's a vesuvian war
staff
moth gideon destroys the mandalorian
ship razor crest
from mormon the devastating moment and
uh in a moment that debunked a lot of
those fan theories that han solo walked
by the razor crest uh
yeah in uh in uh what was it force
awakens so
uh or or rise of skywalker or was that
right
one of those people i uh i uh
was hoping that that was not the case
but unfortunately it is the razer crest
is
smithereens so uh at least that razor
crest maybe there's a new one coming
along
uh gideon sends four robotic dark
troopers to fly down they looked so much
more human
in the last episode that we saw them
nothing so they totally looked like uh
iron giants to me in this episode uh
so they go down and capture the child
and then the light cruiser retreats into
hyperspace
fat and shan say that their agreement is
that they uh they need to help them
to help mando save the child because
that was the deal armor for protecting
the kid and the kid is now
in danger mando seeks out now marshall
cara dune
uh and her help breaking out the
criminal mayfield my boy bill burr
in order to rescue grogu impressed by
grogu's force powers mob gideon informs
dr pershing
the midichlorian donor is available what
a creepy scene that was
like when he pulled out the dark saber
and was like you like it
no touching you like it anyway
that's why he was right not to touch it
but yeah i think it was just the idea of
a lightsaber
uh and man that dark stable is cool it's
cool to see an indoor light you know the
way it uh retracted was interesting
it didn't have that that same like sucks
and it was just kind of like a
blah blah yeah so it went back in very
elegant
uh and i don't know about you tommy but
when he pulled out i guess the best
uh spear from the wreckage of the
razer chris makes sense when he found
that little ball knob i was like
yeah really that that survived intact i
don't
really see a lot of other fuselage in
here but that thing
there's something about that i i feel
like someone theorized that that little
thing was the tracking
yeah which i guess wouldn't have made
sense because it was from season one but
maybe they replaced it if it's a if it's
a replaceable part
i thought that was that would have been
a brilliant theory but yeah that would
have been interesting when uh baby yoda
when groga was playing with it it had a
uh
like a blue part of it and i can't
remember if the blue
part of it was there in season one i'd
have to go back and i can't either
i won't go back i never look back eric
only forward always onward
yeah uh i gotta hand it robert rodriguez
such a great action director
and and he really kept the pacing going
on this episode
you know like the the tension as uh
denjarin was racing back up the hill
to get to the sleeping child you know as
we know these
these dark troopers were coming down
such great like
cutting back and forth uh like
stormtrooper shootouts were really fun i
love how there's like a second wave of
stormtroopers just when you feel like
you're okay there's like
another wave and just like you know in
the series they always keep
coming you never completely run out uh
so yeah this is great and a
heartbreaking
tragic episode in a lot of ways but uh
as we move on to what the deeper meaning
of this episode was i
think you know there's some confusion
over what that tragedy exactly was
like obviously we all felt this pang of
dread at the beginning of the episode
where it's like
the tragedy right we're like oh [ __ ]
what's it gonna be
um and yeah we are very much at a rock
bottom you know
grogu is finally in the hands of moff
gideon
um and that was not the case before he's
been in the hands of dr pershing and the
client but not gideon
mando's longtime ship the razor quest is
gone honestly
how about you tommy that loss hurt a lot
more for me
it was kind of shockingly understated
yeah
it was it was a it was a shocking kind
of like
first of all destruction of a lot of fan
theories which is always an interesting
you know when we when we do this for
work it makes me look at episodes
differently than i would like i'm like
oh man so many people have put so much
emphasis on what the razor crust is and
what it will mean going forward
and now it's just gone uh now it's just
exploded
when you name a ship like that you spend
a lot of time on it and you
build these attachments to it now
granted this is not the millennium
falcon
getting destroyed and i would say this
isn't even the delorean getting
destroyed back to the future
part but it's almost like if you know if
you're watching rebels for four seasons
and then the ghost gets blown up right
you know
but and i would say that yeah and
and i would say that uh much like the
millennium falcon a lot of the like
relationship development between mando
and the child happened in the cockpit of
the razor crest you know
yeah a lot of like mando being a little
more vulnerable than we ever see him
in like those private moments with just
him in the child where he's trying to
like
teach him or discipline him even or you
know like yeah
whatever it's like a lot of those cute
cute kind of father-son moments happened
there if these uh if these dirty whole
walls could talk
you could argue that uh this season has
kind of been setting us up for that
you know they have taken the razor crest
through everything they submerged in
water they patched together with mon
calamari netting they
they had ice spiders tear it to pieces
like the thing has been in rough shape
however i would argue that's like you
know slowly watching
uh your dog start to get sick
and it isn't able to hold itself up
anymore that makes it sadder
in a way that you overshadowed it like
that uh but
yeah this had me wondering what the real
tragedy of the episode was was it grogu
was it the razor crest getting destroyed
why call it the tragedy
because yeah uh grosgu does get in the
hands but obviously it feels like a
false defeat right
he's gonna be rescued in some way right
or
it's gonna be twisted in some way to
where maybe he stays in the hands of the
empire but
not in the way that we see it now uh so
to call it a tragedy feels
weirdly final um but
you know i think the reason why i'm
feeling that kind of like uh
mystery is i really wish we could have
seen pedro pascal's face for this
episode
uh because i think had we seen the look
of despair on his face it would have
helped uh
us gauge how we should feel the
emotional beats of this episode
and there was a moment if you look at
the concept art in the episode at the
very end during the credits
you can see that moment where grogu's
been flown up to the cruiser
with the dark troopers and the art
depicted and being
uh panicked and sobbing and we don't
really get that moment that shot this
episode it's just you see him through
mando's visor and it's just happening
too fast and you don't see how scared
that kid is
but then i realized the true tragedy the
most
human scene i think comes at the very
beginning before all the action
overwhelms us it's some of the most
characterization we get of denjarin when
it comes to his relationship
with the child there's just this little
moment he is playfully repeating his
name just to get him to look up at him
again
grogu
[Music]
and he like loves having a name for this
kid
yeah uh to be able to call him something
to connect with him
um and then he tests his force pull
abilities and then when he does it he
swear he goes dang farrick he swears in
astonishment
uh and he scares the kid for a bit and
he's like no no
it's a good thing what i'm doing but he
feels kind of sad
because he's explaining to this kid what
a lot of parents feel this profound and
very complicated emotion
uh that you know a lot of parents go
through it's that feeling of falling
short of the needs of the child of the
kid that you're no longer
capable of being a true mentor or father
figure
that the kid has kind of outgrown you
and that's kind of a tragic feeling
in a way sure uh and mando has already
of course declared that he's just trying
to transport this child to the jedi that
the kid would be better off with but in
this episode
we see him truly surrender to that fact
that he can't really protect this child
like he knows grogu is too powerful too
you know connected to these other
big powerful things in the universe and
there's
these moments we see it three times he
cannot break through that jedi barrier
to try to protect the kid you could
argue that that barrier even kept that
kid more protected than mando could have
because there's a force field that you
know nobody could penetrate
d if if that force field stayed up for
the whole battle we'd probably
the kid at least would have been okay it
almost felt like a um
a soccer dad who's trying to take his
kid out of the game
but like the referee is blocking him on
the line for the field like no sir
you're you got to stay in the bleachers
he's like i need to get my little boy
out of there
he's getting killed in there he's like
your boy's fine and then your dad goes
yeah and then leaves uh and then robots
come down and take the kid and beam him
up too
yeah as most child sporting events go
yeah so i
i think that uh and then the fact that
like for a lot of the battle
mando was concussed he was knocked on
the ground from this
from whatever this energy field was uh
and that tells us that like it's not
gonna help him to try to physically
protect this kid and i think we might
look back on this episode and realize
this was the moment they became
uh partners true partners it's not just
a
protector uh and protectee it's two
people who are
evenly matched in different ways and
it's a jedi and it's a mandalorian
and uh two historically sparring forces
are able to uh check and balance each
other in cool ways going forward here's
my question to you tommy
are we is the tragedy we're really
seeing here
uh the coming death of dinjarin the
mandalorian
uh are we seeing uh pedro pascal's
character being phased out
oh boba fett or one of these other
characters is going to take over as the
lead of this
interest oh wow yeah i mean i think
i wonder that would be crazy right like
that would that would be
pretty ballsy that would be pretty
amazing not like unprecedented with
these massive shows
though you know there are like usually
one season but so two seasons would be
even more of a long con or not long con
but slow play of like
ultimately this is not a show about the
mandalorian
uh a different mandalorian but uh i
don't i don't know because i i
i wonder i feel like ahsoka tano is
primed to get her own live-action disney
plush show right isn't that like kind of
doesn't that seem more
that or she's being primed to take over
this show right i mean
maybe tommy she's being set up as her
own uh spin-off but
she could be set up and then i could
imagine the show doing a thing where
uh baby yoda where grogu is the
mandalorian of the show going forward
the thing is i have to go back and look
at everything pedro pascal has said
there were some uh like debunked rumors
that he was fired from the show
halfway through the season i think he
has said certain stuff about uh
season three but most of the season
three stuff i've heard has been coming
from filoni and favreau of course
uh and it's come from moff gideon i
don't think he'll be thwarted at the end
of this season
he's going back in season three i don't
know i could see that especially since
pedro pascal his face is not on the show
that's a that's a big deal i i think
he he might be able to part ways with it
he's got other stuff in his career that
he can move on to for sure and i mean
and and what a i mean what a crazy
moment that would be is if he dies in
the season finale and then
season three where we're kind of
figuring out who the new man
quote-unquote mandalorian is going to be
is that right you know we've met
three others in boca ten yeah i was
gonna say we've got bo katan and and
then the other
uh sasha banks his character whose name
escapes me right now
costco reeves um costco costco
that's where keanu does a shopping at
costco that's right costco reeves i
don't wait in line
yeah i'm thinking i'm back
yeah uh he tries to reach a box off the
top shelf he pulls out his gun and just
lays on his back and goes
she says um and then of course there's
also sabine wren who's somewhere out
there oh right
she is a mandalorian as well uh so yeah
there's
there are ways um the ultimate tragedy
the reason we're seeing the razor crests
get destroyed
is we're ultimately seeing the death of
that mandalorian in season three we'll
say pass the torch onto a new
mandalorian
um we're gonna talk more about like some
of the deeper questions we had coming
out of this episode
before we do we want to thank our
friends at manscaped for helping us
sponsor
it a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away men actually shave their balls with
the same razor as their face
just as the razor crest gets destroyed
you need to part ways with that kind of
razor
and embrace the razors from manscaped
the best in men's below the waist
grooming
manscaped is here to stop you from
looking like chewbacca down
there now for all we know mando could be
a never nude but i would imagine that a
cool customer like denjarin would want
to be nice and clean downstairs
manscaped is forever changing the
grooming game with their perfect package
3.0
inside the perfect package you will find
their electric trimmer the lawnmower 3.0
this waterproof and skin safe trimmer
will reduce nicks
this is the droid you're looking for it
also includes the crop preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer
the crop reviver toner spray and
anti-chafing performance boxing briefs
and a very sharp black color that is
downright imperial
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com mandalorian that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
mandalorian may the force be with your
balls and also with yours
okay tommy let's talk about some of the
questions we had first off
what do we think grosgu saw on that
seeing stone
yeah he was there for a long time so
i i mean well the language we got from
ahsoka tano was he could reach out right
he could reach out and maybe another
jedi would sense him
so so i think maybe he was just casting
a wide force net into the uh galaxy that
should try and get
there aren't many jedi's left we know so
i don't know it's going to be
interesting i
you know part of me wants to see luke
skywalker
i've seen some really really like fans
have been
pitching the theory of sebastian stan
who really kind of looks like a young
mark hamill
uh a little bit yeah a little bit enough
i think that you could totally get away
with it i would i don't know like that
could be interesting a d
aged mark hamill might be too we
we could be venturing into uh the
irishman territory with that so
i almost wouldn't mind a recasting of a
younger luke skywalker but uh
uh yeah i don't know what do you think i
well who are the jedi who are still
out there yeah uh luke skywalker's out
there
leia organa is out there obviously
they're not gonna bring back any kind of
carrie fisher i would say
jedi fallen order is out there and
cameron
could totally yeah come in and play
buddy uh tom michaelson on rogue theory
last week pitched an awesome
theory for what that would look like so
i i would love to see that
um i think if we were to see
uh with the exception of calcus that
would be a big move to make him just
kind of a recurring character on the
show or to make him a live-action
character in this universe
they don't normally do that when it
comes to characters just from
the games right they'll do details
they'll do like droids they'll do ships
weapons from the games
um but it's rare to see uh like a human
figure for the game yes
um i think whoever they get uh if
it's gonna be like a short rescue i
think this is going to play into how
grosgu is able to get away from off
gideon
um to have just a figure a hooded figure
and we hear the voice of mark hamill uh
could be one thing
um but yeah i think this is setting up
the events of the finale i think we're
gonna bring in
some jedi figure he could have reached
out to ahsoka tano in that moment i hope
that
ahsoka is not just gonna be limited to
chapter 13
of this of this season she's got to come
back in some ways
she's such a great character i wonder if
the other jedi that grogu reaches out to
will call on ahsoka tano you know what i
mean like say like i can't do this alone
i need your help maybe it will maybe
it'll be one of those things
kind of the the uh the physical
embodiment of all of the force ghosts
reaching out to ray at the end of rise
of skywalker
uh-huh maybe maybe it'll be an actual
like maybe we'll get like three of them
maybe it'll be like all in cloaks but
maybe just their lightsabers will be
what we see or something
yeah it would be exciting to have like a
moment like
uh in attack of the clone so you just
see all these lightsabers igniting
around them in the fighting pit
you know that was such a cool moment to
because jedi had always been
kind of a solitary uh force because you
know in the original trilogy they were
all but extinct
and then the prequels the exciting thing
was we're seeing a lot of jedi and then
they just kind of delivered us that
moment
in attack of the closer it was like
dozens of jedi this is awesome
right so right yeah uh it would be cool
to have a moment like that have multiple
jedi
whoever are left uh or just some
unknowns you know like yeah
this is an opportunity to introduce a
new character that uh
this could have been the character who
helped him survive uh escape order 66
introduce a new wrinkle to it it doesn't
have to be someone we know
um for sure so so all right what do we
think why is boba's explanation of his
father django's history
so important yeah so
this is a big deal we uh had suspected
that jango fett
might not be an actual mandalorian that
he could have been another
you know appropriator of that armor uh
just because some leaders of mandalore
considered him
an imposter they considered him a thief
of that
whole identity but now um
you could just say this is what django
told boba and these are just the stories
a kid is saying about his dad
but it seemed like this was like a
definitive moment yeah it was cool to
see that it was cool to see some
clarification
that jango fett was a mandalorian
foundling so
just kind of settling the debate on that
uh and it makes the story of boba fett
and the story of mandalorian one and the
same both were found lanes
both of them are owners rightful owners
of this kind of armor
all right so why does mando need
mayfield bill burr's character to rescue
grogu
shouldn't he just ask ahsoka to help
well he absolutely should ask is so
gonna help
that's what i'm saying we gotta go back
to ahsoka tano please don't let this be
all we see over in this season she would
be extremely useful
in in uh and getting there now i i'm
worried that we're not going to see her
just because i think
they set up the whole best scar spear to
see mando
fight uh mothgating with a dark saber so
that you have two characters who are not
force sensitive
using these weapons that are evenly
matched
i i'd be more excited to see amanda amof
gideon fight um
but i want her to come back i think she
would be useful when it comes to bill
burr's character
uh he was like specifically an expert at
breaking into uh impossible to break in
facilities he
is like the guy i do love this idea that
we kind of
break him out before we can break grogu
out it does feel like act one
of a fast and furious movie and i think
that india i think that
you know it's talk about fan service
people just want that bill burr
character back for another episode
so it's like where does that fit in oh
perfect okay
so so important to both of us i think
with the razor crest destroyed
how is mando gonna travel now yeah i
know that's that is kind of uh
worrisome because i don't think he's
just gonna take over slave one
i think that would be too confusing for
a lot of fans that is boba fett's ship
it should always stay
boba fett's ship um it i don't think
he's going to join forces with boba fett
on the show i think boba fett's arc is
gonna be these next couple episodes and
then maybe he comes back every now and
then after that because i think just for
casual fans i don't think everyone
following you're gonna be like oh we'll
have two characters who both have the
same kind of armor
and they're just flying on a ship
together the green one is is
boba fett though yeah so i he's gonna
have to get a new ship
uh it could be some other new badass
ship
um that we just immediately appreciate
more he could kind of rebuild the razor
crates i think with the razer crest
destroyed this is you know again more
evidence that
we might might might see the death of
denjarin
this season because that it poses an
interesting transition
right yeah um my god this i mean the
buzz on season three would be crazy if
they did that
and then sticking with this question
tommy uh we have in addition to these
characters we're not sure whether
they're coming back in season three boba
fett ahsoka tano bocatan crees
thrawn are these characters only gonna
appear in season two which of them do
you think could join the main cast in
season three
i mean i think thrawn for sure uh yeah
because i don't know that we're gonna
even see him
maybe at the end of this what have we
got two episodes left for this season
yeah two yeah i could see maybe what at
the end of the finale
like the cut or the the post-credit
scene being the intro
the visual introduction of thrawn uh i
think he's going to be a huge part of
season three
uh and i also think i mean i think all
of them
are going to be back for season three
you know i would be shocked if we didn't
see
any of them the people i think i think
boca tan and thrawn are certainly gonna
be bigger parts of season three than
they were for season two
in my mind yeah i think the way filonia
is doing this similar to how he did it
on rebels and clone wars where like
uh characters aren't in every single
episode they come
and they go and then they're revisited
it's he believes in a star wars universe
where you can just kind of bounce around
to different planets yeah it's nice and
it makes you feel more like
it's yeah it makes it feel more like a
movie than a tv show when it's like
you go away for 45 minutes or so from
these characters and then they'll come
back and then like
it feels like a long the pacing of it is
more cinematic than than uh
telematic yeah um so they all still
exist in this world unless they die
so um i have a feeling that
um that boba fett might be a short-term
thing
um ahsoka and thrawn are obviously
coming back
either on this show or their own
spin-off miniseries or something like
that
uh i do think boca tan uh is coming back
on the show i think the fact that she
is a mandalorian that is kind of the
theme of the show
i think i think she's coming back i
think she has to i think i mean they
have a common enemy in moff gideon and
she represents more of uh some more
answers
for yeah yeah she's on her own arc to
retake mandalore and we're gonna see
that at some point on the show okay
um well now here's another segment of
man doesn't man don'ts it's a
corrections corner where we quickly
recap the theories predictions for
passwords we got right others we got
wrong
uh starting with a man do do yes
good we uh did predict as did many
a lot of people uh thought this was
gonna be the case boba fett was the one
who rescued phoenix shand
at the end of chapter five i could see
her betraying
boba fett and uh and and and uh jinjaren
yeah right now she seems like uh she's
just kind of grateful
to boba fett and the way that like jar
jar was grateful to qui-gon for saving
him like i'm in your service now but
she is her own badass bounty hunter she
might not necessarily think this whole
rescue mission is worth it
right i i don't think it would be like
treachery it would be more self-saving
yeah yeah yeah agreed um okay so a man
don't uh
oh we suggested boba fett must not care
about us getting his armor back
since he was in the same vicinity as
cobb vance for years and years and
didn't bother trying to get it before
but obviously he did want it back all it
took was for someone else to
try to run away with it someone more
deadlier at protecting it than cop band
was
right to fly away to another planet and
then to chase him down to that other
planet
and then get it back yeah i want to know
where he parked the slave one because
that had
been a pretty massive bill when he was
like i haven't used this in
several several decades so yeah
i'm about to pay for parking and get it
out so what is it uh thirty dollars i
still have so many questions
about about boba fett how did he get out
of the sarlacc
what has he been doing has was he the
one hanging out with tusken raiders at
the beginning i don't know if we're
going to get answers to that
to those questions because i don't know
if his whole backstory was
that thought out clearly if he was okay
with cop vamp having his
armor right years cop banta is an idiot
that guy was a he
stumbled across it right you know tired
thanks to
having some money to trade with jawas he
barely was protecting that town on
tatooine
but but that could have gone in here
there and wrecked him at any point
and he must have known where it was if
he knew to watch
mando fly away unless he had no idea
that town was there
the crate dragon kerfuffle is what got
his attention
and then he's like oh [ __ ] that's my
armor all right i'm gonna follow it now
like it's it poses a lot of questions
yes
but something we can uh take credit for
we did correctly
identify moth gideon's troopers as dark
troopers those are
you know heavily armored attack droids
they were not like
force sensitive uh human troopers who
might um
want baby yoda blood to wield
lightsabers
they were just these awesome awesome
droids like iron giants as tommy said
but
not not caring for children but not with
vin diesel's voice
i did wonder why did they send in human
stormtroopers in there and not to send
in a couple of dark troopers into
grog's chamber when he was wrecking it i
think it was just for the gag of
seeing these things get ragged all
around the room yes absolutely
it's like there was some scene on scene
where the dark troopers are like here is
a child
take custody of him now and they're like
okay we got it thanks guys
and then they got choked i think it's
the same the same info
like the same impulse that had moth
gideon send two
kind of barges full of uh of
stormtroopers to just basically get
picked off by
as a diversion like it just shows more
of moff gideon's
like zero regard for life right like
he's like send these
troopers in to guard the child knowing
full well that they're gonna get
absolutely destroyed by him
like because maybe it was a test yeah
maybe it was like i just want to make
sure
he is force sensitive there was like a
little twinge in the
uh when um when when grogu was
uh forced using his force powers on the
troopers
the music kind of almost went into
anakin skywalker's theme from the
prequels whenever he would do something
that hinted towards a turn to vader
like yeah there was like a little i
think i'm sure it was just me
listening for it but i almost know i was
probably there i almost thought for a
second like it was like moff gideon
seeing like
is this perhaps uh compromisable
for sense of force user like is this
someone that we could get to go to the
dark side or
yeah yeah i don't know but um uh but one
last uh
thing i want to uh own up for obviously
with the razor crests destroyed
uh the videos i made about the rise of
skywalker where i suggested it kind of
looks like the razor crest among the
resistance fleet either parked on the
planet or in the big
shot of all the ships together yeah nope
that's not the case now if the razor
crests went boom boom yeah
although it is kind of like i have seen
movies before where like the big thing
at the end is that they
fix the car you know that gets destroyed
so there is i wonder if there's a moment
where like
boba fett's parting gift to mando it's
like and here's the razor crest
completely rebuilt that i somehow had
the blueprints for
yeah well that would be nuts yeah or it
could have just been a thing like the
artists from these movies just like drag
and drop
like i think they some people say in the
background they put one of the trade
federation
back ships in the background yeah those
wouldn't be around
no so um yeah maybe it was that or maybe
it just wasn't there but uh one last
reminder that you can get our uh new
rockstars merch at newarkstarsmerge.com
we got a bunch of great options there
but that is it for this episode of
wikileaks
uh i will be going through this episode
frame by frame in tomorrow's video
some of you will never understand that
because some of you
only look at episode length and the
thumbnail
click on it see it's me and tommy and
are immediately confused and don't wait
for an explanation you just start
commenting
uh subscribe to new rockstars on youtube
though also subscribe to the wikileaks
podcast feed wherever you get your
podcast to get audio versions of the
show
i'll be back tomorrow with easter egg
breakdown we're gonna leave you with our
favorite grogu moment of the
[Music]
episode
you